Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 67. Ausgabe unserer Suche nach der Wahrheit im Universum und wie man das am besten so anstellt. Und ja, für die heutige Ausgabe gibt es einen Ausflug in die Wissenschaft und konkret in die Kernphysik. Trotzdem bleiben wir dem Universum verbunden und wollen mal ein wenig näher auf das Phänomen der Neutronensterne blicken, die ja da draußen eine ganze Menge Aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen. Ja, und um das mal ausreichend beleuchten zu können, bin ich nach Mainz gefahren und begrüße meine Gesprächspartnerin, nämlich Konchettina Svienti. Schönen guten Tag. Wir sind hier in Mainz. Du bist hier Professorin für Kernphysik. Gibt es da noch mal eine genauere Bezeichnung?
Oh, das heißt ganz lang Kern und Hadronenphysik. Wobei Hadronen kommt aus Griechisch und bedeutet schwer. Das heißt irgendwie sagen wir das gleiche, doppel gemoppelt. Aber bin ich Professorin für Kern und experimentelle Kern- und Hadronenphysik. Und wenn das nicht heavy genug war, habe ich mich mit Neutronenstern auch beschäftigt. Die sind dann so richtig heavy.
Genau, das werden wir gleich noch rausfinden. Jetzt wird mich natürlich am Anfang erst mal interessieren, wie du in diese Rolle geraten bist. Bist du auch so eine Wissenschaftlerin von Anfang an?
Ich bin Wissenschaftlerin seit meiner Doktorarbeit. Als ich festgestellt habe, Wissenschaft macht wirklich Spaß. Am Anfang meines Studiums erzähle ich das immer. Meine Studierende wusste ich nicht, dass ich wirklich Physik machen wollte. Ich hatte viele Interessen und Physik war einfach das, was die Leute beim Studierendebüro als Umschlag rausgenommen haben. Ich bin wirklich an dem letzten Tag von der Anmelderphase bei Studierendensekretariat gegangen mit vier Umschlägen. Und ich habe gesagt, ich kann mich nicht entscheiden, nehmen sie eine. Die haben von mir gedacht, die Frau wird nicht so einen langen Weg schaffen.
Was waren denn in den anderen drei drin?
In einer war Ingenieurwissenschaften, weil ich eigentlich bei NASA arbeiten wollte und ich wusste, man muss Ingenieurwissenschaften studieren. In einem anderen war Literatur, weil ich gerne Bücher und Poesie und so weiter immer wieder gemacht habe. War Physik eben da drin. Und das letzte war Erdwissenschaften oder Geologie, wie man das in Italien nennt, weil ich an der Zeit verliebt war in einer, der das studieren wollte. Aber das war so nebenbei gesagt. Und ich konnte mich wirklich nicht entscheiden. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich nehme sie mal einfach eine, kam raus, Physik. Und am Anfang war ziemlich heavy. Also ich wusste nicht, ob das die richtige Entscheidung war. Dann habe ich angefangen, während meiner Diplomarbeit wirklich Spaß zu haben. Und ich habe gesagt, ich mag jetzt Doktor. Und dann irgendwann konnte ich mir das Leben ohne Physik nicht mehr vorstellen. Das war Liebe zweite Blick sozusagen. Weil das war alles, also wenn man einfach guckt, was meine Interessen waren, das ist auch Kunst. Man hat mit der Natur zu tun. Es ist auch manchmal, wenn man das Universum beobachtet, es ist auch Poesie drin. Man arbeitet zwar nicht bei NASA, man kann aber Dinge untersuchen, die eben NASA schaut. Das heißt, es ist auch ein bisschen Ingenieurwissenschaften, nur tiefer.
Da ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass keine Physiker bei der NASA arbeiten.
Und das hat mit der Natur zu tun. Das heißt, im Grunde genommen ist auch sozusagen Erdwissenschaften, das ist alles was und man ist frei. Man kann einfach, der Treiber, wie heißt das, Treiber auf Deutsch, ist einfach die eigene Leidenschaft. Das will ich jetzt untersuchen, das finde ich spannend. Ich mache mal das und man wird dafür bezahlt. Das finde ich genial. Also ich kann mir das Leben nicht mehr anders vorstellen. Ganz verständlich Frage zu stellen und dann eine Antwort zu suchen. Das finde ich.
Aber nicht zu studieren war keine Option?
Nee, meine Familie nicht zu studieren war keine Option. Sozusagen, wenn man aus einer Familie kommt, die in der 60er-Jahre gekämpft hat, damit jeder an der Uni dürfte, dann müssen die Kinder an der Uni. Das war keine eigentliche Option. Und am Anfang hat wirklich kein Spaß gemacht, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Zu viel Mathe oder was? Nee, Mathe war kein Problem. Eigentlich Mathe habe ich immer gelebt, aus irgendeinem Grund auch immer. Nur habe ich am Anfang die Physik nicht verstanden, denn Fehler machen wir heutzutage auch, wie wir oft unterrichten, sozusagen Wahrheiten zu geben. Und diese Wahrheiten sollten die Studierenden bitte lernen. Und das war für mich ein No-Go. Ich habe gesagt, ich muss das einfach verstehen, also so einfach auswendig lernen. Oder ich hatte das nicht verstanden, was eigentlich Physik war. Und als ich angefangen habe, und das war eben bei meiner Diplom-Arbeit, selber Forschung zu machen, selber mir eine Frage auszusuchen und an der Lösung zu arbeiten, auf einmal habe ich gesagt, das macht aber verdammt viel Spaß. Und seitdem macht es immer noch verdammt viel Spaß. Deshalb mache ich das weiter.
Was ist denn Physik?
Was ist Physik? Physik ist der Versuch, das Universum zu verstehen, ist so allgemein. Der Sagan hat das einmal so schön formuliert. Der hat einfach gesagt, Physik ist diese Not von unserem eigenen Kind. Als Kind ist man immer daran gewohnt, immer zu fragen, warum. Man hat diese Neugier ständig. Im Laufe der Jahre verlieren die meisten diese Neugier. Warum? Einige verlieren das nicht. Das sind Physiker. Das heißt, es ist mehr, diese ständige Neugier nachzugehen. Daraus macht man eine Wissenschaft.
Ich glaube, was auch dazu gehört, ist ein Gefühl dafür zu haben, dass eigentlich noch nicht alles erzählt ist.
Genau. So wie die Never-Ending-Story. Man macht einen Buch auf und erst mal ist die Geschichte immer neu. Hängt das davon ab, in welchen Jahrzehnten man diese Geschichte liest. Wir lesen immer wieder die gleiche Geschichte vom Universum. Die Newton und Einstein und so weiter, die haben immer das gleiche Kapitel gelesen. Wenn wir das heute lesen, lesen wir nicht, aber der gleiche Kapitel, die Newton damals gelesen hat. Und man kommt am Ende dieser Kapitel, und es gibt noch genauso viele Seiten, die weiß sind. Die muss man jetzt füllen. Und einfach geht diese Geschichte immer weiter. Es wäre, als ob die Natur uns selber irgendwas erzählen würde, und wir müssen einfach aufschreiben. Erstmal muss man verstehen, was sie sagt, und dann schreiben wir das aus. Manchmal findet man heraus, wir haben das fast verstanden, wir müssen das einfach korrigieren. Und das macht dann Fortschritt. Wenn ich auf einmal feststelle, was hier in diesem Kapitel stand, ist das aber nicht so. Ich habe jetzt irgendwas Neues gemessen, stimmt nicht, was da steht. Und dann kann man das einfach weglöschen und sagen, nee, der neue Verständnis ist, dass das so funktioniert. Und das Großartige, und deshalb sage ich, ich kann mir das nicht anders vorstellen, dass man als Physiker beitragen kann. An diesem großen Buch ist Literatur. Deshalb sage ich, von allen Interessen, die ich hatte, im Grunde genommen bringt Wissenschaft alle zusammen. Bringt die Physik alle zusammen. Und ich finde die Kunst, ich finde die Poesie, ich schreibe an einem Buch und ich untersuche Dinge, die auch NASA nachforscht, das heißt, ich bin ein kleiner NASA, mini Hubble, so Hubble auf der Erde. Und das finde ich spannend, immer noch.
Das Studium war dann aber in Italien?
Ja, das Studium war in Italien, meine Doktorarbeit war in Italien auch. Und dann nach der Doktorarbeit war immer die Aussage, okay, ein paar Jahre ins Ausland. Und da bin ich nach Deutschland das erste Mal gekommen als Alexander von Umbelt-Stipendiatin auf der anderen Seite des Rheins, wie die Felser sagen, auf der falschen, ich war in Hessen. Und da bin ich ein paar Jahre geblieben. Und dann habe ich meinen ersten Ruf nach meiner Heimatuniversität, also zurück nach Italien, bekommen. Katania, meine Heimatuniversität wollte mich als Professorin haben. Ja, genau. Bin ich zurückgekommen. Und wie ein Kollege von mir damals das formuliert hat, pass auf, wer einmal die Alpen überquert hat, befindet sich immer auf die falsche Seite. Habe ich festgestellt, nach zwei Jahren Italien, nach so einigen Jahren in Deutschland, konnte ich mich nicht mehr einleben. Da sage ich immer wieder, die Möglichkeiten, die man in Deutschland hat, Forschung zu machen. So und nicht nur an, was Gelder betrifft, auch an Infrastrukturen, auch an Volkerverständigung. Also was die Öffentlichkeit oder wie die Öffentlichkeit die Forschung wahrnimmt und so weiter, da liegen zwischen Italien und Deutschland Welten. Und da habe ich gesagt, ich käme mal wieder nach Deutschland zurück und da bin ich in Mainz gelandet, jetzt auf der richtigen Seite von falser Seite betrachtet.
Was ist denn da der Unterschied?
Also erstmal ist, ich denke, das hat zum einen zu tun, wie viel Geld von politischer Seite in der Forschung investiert wird. Das hat auch damit zu tun, wie Politik überhaupt in den beiden Länder funktioniert. Wir haben uns bei dieser Pressemitteilung kennengelernt. Es war das erste Mal, dass ich Frau Wanka traf. Und ich bin die Ministerin für Forschung. Und ich bin sprachlos geblieben. Also was für einen Know-how diese Frau hat, wie sie redet, wie sie nah an Forschung ist. Wir haben nur als typisches Beispiel von Ministerin für Forschung in Italien. Das war vor einigen Jahren Maria Stella Gelmini. Ich weiß nicht, ob du davon gehört hast. Das war die Frau, die damals über das Tunnel vom CERN zu Gran Sasso geredet hat, die Talen gebaut hat, um die Neutrinos vom CERN nach Gran Sasso zu schießen. Gran Sasso ist einer der größten Laboren, die wir in Italien haben und das war ein Projekt, eine Neutrinostrahl vom CERN direkt in Gran Sasso zu schießen. Das kleinste Problem ist, dass Neutrino praktisch unberührt die komplette Materie so durchqueren können. Die wechselwirken gar nicht. Man braucht kein Tunnel zu bilden und da hat sie über diese Tunnel geredet. So ist das Niveau. Ich kann mich, also vielleicht habe ich über Politik ein bisschen später angefangen zu lesen und was zu verstehen, aber ich kann in mein komplettes italienisches Leben nicht daran erinnern, je ein Minister für Forschung gehört zu haben, der über Forschung ein Schimmer Ahnung hatte. Das fängt schon da an, weil in dem Moment, wenn aus der Politik her gut über Forschung geredet wird, wenn Politiker Ahnung über Forschung haben, dann wird bei der Öffentlichkeit viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit für Forschung geben. Und das macht das Ganze anders. Und ich könnte, da ich leidenschaftlich Physikerin bin, ich könnte mir mein Leben als Wissenschaftlerin in Italien nicht mehr vorstellen. Ich wollte einfach dort zurückkommen, wo ich wirklich festgestellt habe, es ist nicht nur, also es ist einer Seite mehr Geld, mehr Investition, aber auch viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit, viel mehr Wertschätzung für das, was ich tue.
Mehr Selbstverständnis vielleicht?
Und trotz, dass ich Sizilianerin bin, also ich bin sehr mit meinem Land einfach verbunden. Ich bin am Meer geboren, hier grau heute und das Meer ist ein bisschen weiter weg und es riecht nicht wie mein Meer, aber trotzdem, sage ich, da fühle ich mich ja komplett als Wissenschaftlerin, weil ich auch immer ständig Ansprechpartner habe, die auf dem Niveau sind, wo Forschung Ansprechpartner braucht. Auf jedem Level und nicht nur politisch, auch wirklich öffentlichkeits- mäßig und das finde ich großartig, dass man einfach immer wieder auch gefragt wird, was tust du und was nutzt uns und warum ist das so großartig und die hören zu bei jeder Kategorie Kinder, Jugendlichen, das finde ich einfach genial.
Hier, das ist das Institut für Kernphysik.
Johannes Gutenberg-Universität Mainz.
Genau, da befinden wir uns jetzt gerade. Da gibt es nicht nur einen großen Campus, sondern hier gibt es auch tolle Beschleuniger, habe ich gerade gesehen. Beeindruckende Gebäude, ist ja schon relativ sportliche Aufstellung für eine Uni. Erwartet man ja jetzt nicht gerade, dass man jetzt auch noch mal so ein Teilchenbeschleuniger im Hinterhof hat.
Ja, also das ist eben was möglich war, dank zum einem der Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft und zum anderen auch vom Land Rheinland-Pfalz. Die haben daran geglaubt, dass sozusagen Forschung hauptnah für Studierende, nicht nur die Johannes-Guttenberg-Universität weltweit in Forschungssache gut profilieren kann, sondern auch das Lernen an der Uni in Physik unglaublich verbessern kann. Und das merken wir immer wieder. Da gibt es diese neue englische Schlagworte, Research-oriented Teaching. Das bedeutet de facto, wir lassen mal die Bücher ein bisschen beiseite und wir gucken, was macht Physik einfach Physik. Was bedeutet, Forschung zu machen, unabhängig davon, dass man viele neue Dinge einfach lernen kann. Aber auch, wie macht man Forschung? Wie lernt man von dem Fehler? Das ist sozusagen nicht die Pressemitteilung-Forschung, wo alles super toll läuft, sondern auch, dass einige Dinge schief laufen und eigentlich, wenn irgendwas schief läuft, dann lernen wir viel mehr von dieser Art kritisches Denken. Was habe ich falsch gemacht? Wie kann ich das verbessern? Ist das wirklich die Antwort, die ich suchte oder ich bin selber, ich bin gerade dabei, mich selber zu überzeugen? Das ist die Lösung. Und das haben wir die letzte, also die letzten Stufe von dieser Beschleuniger wurde vor zehn Jahren gebaut, zehn, zwölf Jahren. Und da sehen wir immer wieder, sind nicht nur Forscher vom Ausland, die hierher kommen, um an unsere Beschleuniger zu forschen, sondern auch viele Gruppen von Studierenden, die hier Physik lernen, die auch die Möglichkeit haben, ihre eigene kleines Projekt hier durchzuführen.
Das heißt, was man jetzt vielleicht so unterstellen könnte, so Mainz, man sitzt hier in der Provinz oder so, ist alles gar nicht wahr, hier ist sehr viel internationaler Austausch.
Ja, und der Punkt ist, ich denke, ich habe mich oft geärgert über diese Tatsache, dass Mainz manchmal wie ein Dorf sich benimmt. Und der Bürgermeister von Mainz hat einmal gesagt, die anderen sind auch stolz darauf. Also es ist so für viele, also insbesondere was Forschung betrifft, wenn man nicht wirklich tief in eine sehr bestimmte Thema ist, da findet man Mainz auf der Landkarte nicht. Für die Leute, die an sehr bestimmten Forschungthemen interessiert sind, selbst in den USA, die kennen uns, weil wir sind die sozusagen Competition von denen. Unser Ziel jetzt langsam auch mit vielen anderen Maßnahmen, die wir durchführen, ist das eben Mainz nicht nur für die, die unglaublich tief in der Forschung sind, auf der Landkarte steht, sondern auch für alle anderen Leute. Und dass wir sagen, hallo, wir sind auch da und wir sind kein Dorf. Wir sind weltoffen. Ja, das ist sicherlich viel regional, da gibt es aber Studie deutschlandweit, was Bachelor insbesondere betrifft, da kommen Studierende nur aus der Region und sei es Rheinland-Pfalz oder Bayern, es ist einfach egal. Da bekommen wir viel mehr Studierende jetzt zum Beispiel für das Master oder für die Promotion hierher. Also in dem machen wir uns jetzt doch bekannt. Aber Schüler kriegen wir, die haben erstmal haben wir jetzt, wir nennen das Teilchenakademie gemacht, also sind Schüler von den letzten Klassen, die können zum Beispiel hierher kommen und zwei Wochen lang an unsere Beschleuniger forschen. Und wie üblich, wie alle anderen Universitäten haben wir Tag der offenen Tür und Physik am Samstagmorgen und alles drum und dran das komplette Paket.
Aber es ist ja auch so ein Trend, den man bei manchen Universitäten sieht, dass man sich sehr viel früher und sehr viel intensiver mit weiterführenden Schulen mindestens vernetzt. Einfach auch um dort schon Schülern mehr ein Gefühl für, wie so ein Forschungsalltag aussehen kann, geben zu können.
Insbesondere, weil es immer wieder und alle neue Schulsysteme haben die Sache eigentlich in der Zusammenhang nicht viel geändert. Es wird Physik aus den Büchern unterrichtet und dann die Schüler sagen, das macht mir ja keinen Spaß. Ja sozusagen, das ein bisschen von der Bücher, von der Mathematik rauszunehmen. Ja, man braucht das auch, aber de facto Physik ist Forschen und Forschen ist, sich neugierige Fragen zu stellen und dann ein Projekt auf die Beine stellen, die diese Fragen beantwortet. Und das probieren wir mit unterschiedlichen Projekten immer wieder.
Was war denn die Doktorarbeit eigentlich seiner Zeit? Was war denn so?
Bei meiner Doktorarbeit, also das hat eigentlich bei meiner Diplomarbeit angefangen. Und zwar wir hatten, wir waren sehr klug und wir wollten von allen unserer Lehrer wissen, was bieten sie als Diplomarbeit an. Und einer der Lehrer, der wurde dann auch meine sozusagen Diplomvater und Doktorvater, der kam, okay wir machen Schwereonend- Forschung, also man nimmt zwei super heavy Dinge und schmeißt die gegeneinander. Und die Idee dabei ist, Neutronsternmaterial im Labor zu erzeugen. Und dann hat er angefangen über Neutronsterne zu erzählen. Und das war Liebe, erster Blick habe ich gesagt, solche Objekte muss ich erst mal verstehen und es macht Spaß. Und das habe ich eben bei meiner Diplomarbeit und dann auch bei der Doktorarbeit habe ich das auch gemacht. Ich habe Kollisionen zwischen Kernen und der Sucht wie am Hella C am Zern, nur bei viel kleineren Energien. Der Welt. Und da habe ich solche Kollisionen und der Sucht umzugucken, wie Sternmaterie oder welche Eigenschaften die Materie, die im Sternen drinnen ist, überhaupt hat. Was für Eigenschaften hat diese Materie. Und dann im Laufe meiner Karriere, es war immer lustig, weil ich habe immer wieder Feld geändert. So schwere Ionen, Kollisionen habe ich nicht mehr gemacht. Ich habe angefangen mit radioaktiven Kernen zu arbeiten. Jetzt hier arbeite ich mit Elektronen und untersuche Reaktionen von Elektronen am Kernen, also viel leichteren Dinge. Ziel immer zu verstehen, wie diese Sterne überhaupt funktionieren. Also das ist einfach das große Herz. Also wenn man einfach sagen würde, das große Herz, wo steht, ich liebe Physik, hat der Form eine Neutronenstern für mich.
Okay, na dann wären wir ja schon so ein bisschen beim Thema, aber ich glaube bevor wir irgendwie Neutronensterne uns genauer anschauen können, müssen wir vielleicht erstmal Sterne an sich verstehen und uns irgendwie dem Thema äußern. Ich meine, irgendwann als Kind, irgendwann hat man vielleicht auch mal verstanden, dass die Sonne nur ein Stern von vielen ist oder dass die Sonne überhaupt ein Stern ist. Und natürlich auch, dass in gewisser Hinsicht so dieses ganze Hin und Her der Sterne letzten Endes, die die Quelle allen Lebens sind, weil was nicht einmal durch den Stern gegangen ist, das kommt nicht rein in den Mensch. Was, also ich hatte ja hier auch schon verschiedene Sendungen über das Planetensystem etc., wie sich das baut. Sterne waren noch gar nicht so sehr im Fokus bisher. Sterne sind ja eigentlich so die Dinge, die groß genug sind, um überhaupt erst mal anfangen zu leuchten. Ich glaube, darauf kann man sich schon mal einigen. So, das heißt dort fallen dann Dinge zusammen. Was ist sozusagen die Qualität eines Sterns gegenüber den anderen Objekten, die sie zu Sternen macht?
Was ist die Qualität eines Menschen, der das zu Menschen macht? Das Problem, ich weiß, das Hauptproblem beim Sternen ist einfach, dass man sich mit diesem Thema nicht so oft befasst, es sei denn, man ist in irgendeinem Planetarium, weil die grundlegende Frage ist, wie ist die Big Bang überhaupt entstanden, was war davor und in den ersten drei Minuten und dann Exoplaneten. Also alles, was in der Mitte war, das sind nur Sternen, ja die sind doch da, man kann die immer wieder beobachten. Also die erste Frage, was ist eine Stern? Eine Stern ist ein System, wo die erste Kernreaktion stattgefunden hat, wo das Gas, also man hat im Universum nicht so viel, aber ein bisschen Gas aus dem Big Bang, diese langweilige, da war nichts mehr, das ist Gas. Und dann in einigen Regionen vom Universum ist die Dichte vom Gas so groß, dass durch kleine Fluktuationen, heißt das, eine Moleküle bewegt sich mal statt links, bewegt er sich nach rechts. Dann kommt so zu einer Instabilität von der Schwerkraft und diese Wolke fällt in sich zusammen. Und je mehr das zusammen fällt, desto mehr heißer wird drinnen. Dann fällt das noch zusammen und heißer wird, weil der Druck drinnen wird immer kleiner.
Heiß an diesem Moment erst mal nur heißt nicht total kalt.
Ja, genau. Es sind immer die Temperaturen vom Sternen. Bis auf einmal die Temperatur so groß wird, dass die erste ein Proton plus ein Proton macht ein Deuterium und lässt Energie frei in Gang gesetzt wird. Das ist so die erste Kernreaktion und dann auf einmal fängt das Lebenszyklus eines Sterns. Dann auf einmal diese Energie, die durch diese erste eins plus eins macht zwei. Ich sage immer, die Mathematik von den Sternen ist trivial. Eins plus eins macht zwei plus Energie und die Energie bläst das ganze Gas, das noch da stand, einfach weg und dann leuchtet diesen Ding auf einmal. Und diesen Ding ist schwer. Manchmal kann man sich das kaum überlegen, wenn man diese schöne Bilder vom Hubble sieht, wie viel Masse in so einer kleinen Portion vom Raum einfach da sein kann. Also wenn der Stern sein Leben anfängt, da sind schon 10 oder 30 Kilogramm dabei, wenn das leicht ist. Also es sind Objekte, die mindestens so schwer sind wie unsere Sonne.
Oder mal vielleicht mit der Erde verglichen. Wie viele Erden muss man zusammenwerfen, bis es anfängt zu brennen?
Jetzt muss ich rechnen, weil das hat auch mit, wie groß das Radius ist. Wie viel von dieser normalen Materie, wie groß von einem Volumen. Weil man muss eben die Dichte erreichen, wo Protonen einfach so einer neben dem anderen sind, dass das zu einem Deuterium kommen kann. Ehrlich gesagt, eine Zahl hab ich nicht.
Können wir das nachchecken? Wir haben ja zum Beispiel den Jupiter, der ist ja sehr, sehr groß und er hat im Prinzip, hätte der wohl auch genug Masse, um irgendwie im Prinzip auch irgendwann mal zu einem Stern zu werden, nur dass er von allem anderen nicht so richtig, dass die anderen Planeten mit ihrer ganzen Anziehungskraft verhindern, dass das so zusammenkommt.
Ja, aber Stern ist irgendwas Lebendiges. Also wenn man einfach der Stern am Ende ihres Lebens sieht, wenn das zum Red Giant oder White Dwarf, also rote Riesen heißen die, das sind eben keine Sterne mehr, sind einfach Remnants. Das heißt, ein Planet als Stern zu bezeichnen, würde ich nicht, weil das Innen nicht so viel los ist. Ich weiß, man sieht die, die im Himmel leuchten, sehen unglaublich friedlich und ruhig, sind die aber keine friedliche Unruhige. Also man merkt das schon, wenn man heutzutage schöne Aufnahme von der Sonne sieht, wie unruhig unsere Sonne ist. Aber da sind alle Sterne so, weil durch die Rotation, weil dadurch, dass die Wolke einfach zusammenfällt, dann fängt das auch zu rotieren an. Durch die Rotation, durch Magnetfelder, durch alles sind keine ruhige Systeme Planeten, sind, ja ich würde nicht sagen, tote Klumpen von Materie, aber die haben keine innere Feuer, wenn man das so sagen will. Und dann geht die Geschichte immer weiter. Die Sterne leben Millionen Jahre, die Astronomen, also nicht ich, aber die sind unglaublich gut, die können die auch einsortieren, also in welchem Stadium von ihrem Leben sind. Und die meisten befinden sich in diesem Stadium, der dauert am längsten, wo eins plus eins macht zwei. Weil, wenn die Ursprung Materie einfach Wasserstoff ist, dann kann einfach eins plus eins macht zwei. Irgendwann ist das eins weg, weil man hat das gesamte Wasserstoff zum Deuterium. Das heißt, auf einmal ist diese innere Kraft, ich sag mal Kraft, aber es ist falsch, diese innere Energie, die dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Gravitation nicht das komplett kaputtkriegt, ist weg. Das heißt, diese Stern, weil jetzt ist es eine echte Stern, fällt in sich zusammen. Dadurch wird drinnen noch heißer und dann kann 2 plus 2 macht 4. Und dann geht das weiter. Und dann kommt 4 plus 4, Houston, we have a problem, weil 4 plus 4 macht Beryllium 8, der ist instabil. Und da geht es darum, aber das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte, erzähl ich dir irgendwann anders, um diesen Zustand vom Leben, den Heulzustand in dem Kohlenstoffkern. Da ist der Zustand, wo in einem Stern eben 4 plus 4 plus 4 auf einmal sich zusammenkommen können und ich kann anfangen, in dem Stern Kohlenstoff zu produzieren. Und dann geht das weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, bis ich Eisen produziert habe. Dann, wenn ich Eisen produziert habe, kann ich nicht mehr Energie durch Fusionen überhaupt hinkriegen. Und da hängt das End von dem Stern davon ab. Wie schwer war dieser Stern überhaupt? Wenn meine ursprüngliche Stern mindestens vier, fünf Solarmasse schwer war, dann, was danach passiert, ist das schönste Phänomen, das überhaupt im Universum zu sehen ist, ist eine Supernova-Explosion. Und am Ende, was übrig bleibt, ist eine Neutronenstern. Und warum ich immer das so toll fand, ist, dass diese Neutronenstern, wir nennen die auch Pulsare, abgesehen von den Eigenschaften, die kann ich dann auch kurz berichten, aber was Großartiges ist, es ist ein kleines Objekt, der unglaublich stark rotiert. Und was wir auf der Erde messen, ist diese Radiosignal von einem rotierenden Objekt. Die kann man im Internet suchen. Bei Hubble, die haben das wirklich. Viele sind auch im Internet zu finden, die kann man hören. Die haben das Ganze so analysiert und transformiert, die man einfach eine Frequenz hören kann. Und da sage ich, das ist einfach den Schwanengesang große Giganten. Das ist sozusagen für mich heißt, das ist ein Stern, der nicht sterben will. Weil normalerweise, den letzten Schritt, wenn das ein bisschen schwerer gewesen wäre, wäre danach ein schwarzes Loch. Also ein schwarzes Loch kommt Licht nicht raus, wir können die nicht sehen. Wir können jetzt die sehen, weil wir Gravitationswellen messen können. Aber im Prinzip, ein schwarzes Loch ist ein schwarzes Nichts. Denn Neutronstern ist ein kleines Stück davor. Das heißt, wenn der ursprüngliche Stern ein bisschen leichter war, dann stirbt sie nicht. Und das finde ich faszinierend. Wir gehen davon aus, man kann die NuA auf diese Weise beobachten. Es werden neue Missions sein bei NASA. In Zusammenarbeit auch mit der ESA, um zum Beispiel die Radien für solche Objekte besser zu messen. Oder die Massen. Aber de facto kann man nicht so. Ich nehme mal eine Raumfahrt. Ich fliege mal da hin. Athena, A-T-H-E-N-A. Der Grund ist, wir wissen jetzt, es gibt viele unterschiedliche astronomische Methoden, wie man zum Beispiel die Massen von solchen Objekten messen kann. Und wir wissen, Neutronensterne haben eine Masse, die zwischen zwei und dreimal die Masse unserer Sonne ist. Was die Radien betrifft, da gibt es wirklich sehr grobe Abschätzungen. Das heißt, die gehen zwischen 5 Kilometer und 10 Kilometer. Jetzt muss man sich das überlegen. Wir haben eine Masse, die zwischen zwei und dreimal die Masse unserer Sonne ist. In ein System, das 70.000 Mal kleiner ist. Also 10 Kilometer, das Radius von Frankfurt. Das heißt, das typische Beispiel, das ich immer wieder nehme, ich nehme einen Löffel von dieser Materie und das wiegt wie die gesamte Menschheit. Also dreimal die Masse unserer Sonne in 10 Kilometer Radius. Das heißt, alle die Modellierungen, die wir machen, also was die Theoretiker machen, die gehen davon aus. Allgemeine Relativitätstheorie funktioniert, wie wir das kennen. Elektromagnetismus, weil diese Systeme haben auch unglaublich starke Magnetfelder, sind alle Elektronen von den Atomen, die einfach draußen geblieben sind. Wir gehen davon aus, dass das Elektromagnetismus, wie wir das hier auf der Erde kennen, wir haben das bis ins Detail einfach getestet, dass das auch bei dieser Systeme einfach funktioniert. Wir wissen das aber nicht. Das heißt, jeder einzelne Messung sei es auch diejenige, die tief unter der Erde stattfinden können, dazu beitragen, zusammen mit der astronomischen Beobachtung, dass wir diese verrückte Naturscherz fast einfach verstehen können.
Jetzt muss ich aber nochmal ein bisschen nachfragen. Ich weiß, es gibt verschiedene Sternarten. Soweit ich es bisher rausgehört habe, richten sich diese Arten einer Zeit nach dem Zustand, in dem sich dieser Stern befindet. Aber es hat mehr oder weniger alles damit zu tun, wie viel Masse ursprünglich zusammengesunken ist. Wenn es jetzt eine kritische Masse gibt, ab der sich ein Stern bildet, frage ich mich, warum sind dann nicht alle sozusagen gleich? Weil die Masse muss ja erst mal zusammenkommen. Ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt ist es dann eine Sonne, also ein Stern. An dem Zeitpunkt müssten ja irgendwie alle mal gewesen sein. Also alle müssten ja quasi ab dem Moment, wo genug Masse zusammen ist, ist es ein Stern. Warum sind dann nicht alle gleich? Wie kommt mehr Masse dazu? Also sind dann die größeren Sterne alle Sterne, die sich noch mit anderen Sternen zusammengetan haben? Oder sind die dann nachträglich noch gewachsen?
Also es kann natürlich sein, dass viel mehr Massen zusammenfällt. Es kann aber auch sein, dass einfach eine Stern entsteht, wo große Remnants von alten Sternen waren.
Überbleibsel von alten Sternen.
Es kann sein, dass in den zwei Rotierenden, da gibt es oft, dass so eine Neutronenstern zum Beispiel mit irgendeiner Freund, da kann eine rote Riese sein oder irgendwas Ähnliches in der Nähe ist, dann sorgt einfach Material aus dem roten Riese raus. Es kann alles möglich sein. Das ist der Grund, warum es so unterschiedliche Massen gibt.
Okay, aber sind die meisten Sterne von der kleinen Art?
Die meisten sind von der kleinen Art. Wenn man diese Russell-Diagramm guckt, wo die Astronomen sind super gut, einfach alle Sterne zusammenbringen, dann sieht man, dass die meisten stehen in diese sonnenartigen Dinge, aber dann gibt es Ausreise.
Das heißt, wir haben eigentlich so einen herkömmlichen Stern. So einen normalen Standardstern.
Ja, wir haben da einen Standardstern.
Der nicht so besonders ist, gar nicht so interessant ist.
Doch, das Großartige an der Sonne ist, dass es so nah ist. Das heißt, wir können wirklich anhand der Sonne gut verstehen, wie Sterne überhaupt funktionieren. Also wenn man zum Beispiel so der Stadius nach der Wasserstoffverbrennung beobachten möchte, man muss eben eine rote Riese suchen. Und der nächste ist Arcturus und es ist in der nächsten möglichen Galaxien, da kommen wir nicht dahin, um das wirklich gut zu beobachten. Also die Sonne ist für, sagen wir mal so, ich würde mal sagen, dass für Astronomen ist die Sonne wie meine Beschleuniger hier in Mainz. Ja, das ist nicht so was Besonderes, aber ich kann das wirklich. Ja, ich kann unglaublich viel lernen.
Okay, ich wollte ja jetzt die Sonne nicht schlecht reden, nur um so ein bisschen zu verstehen, unsere Sonne ist normal. Aber aus unserer Sonne wird dann auch kein Neutronenstern?
Weil das zu leicht ist. Das heißt, um Neutronensternen zu erzeugen, ich muss genauso viel Massen haben, dass ich dann, nachdem ich das ganze Wasserstoff und Helium einfach verbraucht habe, genauso viel Masse, also in dem Moment, wenn im Inneren ich keine Energiequelle mehr habe, dann drückt die Schwerkraft auf dem Kern des Sterns. Und in dem Moment, wenn ich nicht genug Masse habe, dann ist der Druck drinnen nicht genug, dass ich diese Erhöhung von Temperatur haben kann, dass ich schwere Elemente produzieren kann. Wenn ich nicht bis zum Eisen komme, dann werde ich keine Supernova einfach bekommen. Und die Neutronenstern, so gehen die Modelle im Moment davon aus. So eine exotische Stern kann nur entstehen, in dem Moment, wenn ich durch eine Supernova-Explosion, eine Art Shockwave habe, der die Elektronen in den Atomkernen hineinpresst, sodass ich so eine Art, man nennt das Pasta, man nennt das wirklich Pasta, von Kernen habe, die eben die höchste Dichte, die wir überhaupt im Universum haben, erreicht werden kann. Das heißt, ich brauche wirklich so eine schwere Masse, damit die Gravitation ihre Aufgabe erledigen kann und diese kleine Stern erzeugen kann.
Das heißt, um nochmal bei unserer Sonne zu bleiben, wenn unsere Sonne irgendwann mal ihre Hauptaktivität, der Kernfusion, also den Verbrennungszustand, irgendwann abschließt, weil nicht mehr genug zum Verbrennen da ist, dann wird was passieren?
Da wird einfach auslöschen. Wir werden nicht mehr da sein. Die zweite Phase, die vom Rote Riese, wird die Sonne erreichen. Das wird sich dermaßen ausblasen, dass die gesamte Erde und noch weitere Teile vom Sonnensystem komplett von diesen aufblasenden Sternen gefressen werden. Wir werden beide nicht da sein. Das dauert noch ein paar Millionen Jahre. Also keine Sorgen.
Also meine Atome werden das auf jeden Fall noch erleben.
Und dann wird die nächste Phase anstarten. Und dann wird einfach die Gravitation, wenn das kein Feuer mehr drin ist, wird das einfach wieder ein bisschen verkleinert. Und das wird so tot bleiben wie ein Dorf, wie ein ganz normaler, brässlicher... Da bleibt einfach so ein Klumpen Materie über... Das ist nicht spannend.
Ja, aber der kühlt dann aus, und dann ist da einfach so ein schwarzer Block, der irgendwie darauf wartet, von irgendwas anderem gefressen zu werden.
Der dann irgendwie in diese Recycle vom Universum wieder einfach genommen wird.
Und in diesem ganzen... Da wird ja dann auch wieder viel Staub entstehen, und der wird sich dann vielleicht irgendwann wieder zusammenfinden, und dann kann es ja sein, dass dann daraus unter Umständen nochmal eine größere Sonne entsteht. Und dann haben wir genau den Sternentyp, oder vielleicht nicht genau, aber dann hätten wir unter Umständen einen Sternentyp, der im Prinzip denselben Prozess dann irgendwann nochmal startet. Aber dann, wenn die komplette Phase der Kernfusion durch ist, so schwer ist, dass sich nicht einfach nur aufbläht, sondern es wird so von der ganzen Materie so sehr alles wieder zusammen gedrückt, dass dann diese Paste entsteht.
Genau.
Also quasi so eine, wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen? Das ist dann irgendwie so nur noch so ein grünes...
Also der Punkt ist einfach, man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass das einfach so ist. Also ich hab diese... Der Kern der Stern, also wenn man das Ganze einfach zurückverfolgt, ist einfach, im Drinnen ist Eisen, dann hab ich immer leichtere Elemente. Ja, bis zum Wasserstoff ist ganz am Rande. Ich erzeuge keine Energie mehr drin. Also die Gravitation jetzt pusht die Sache einfach zusammen. Indem das zusammenpusht, erhitzen sich alle Schalen. Außer diese Eisen. Bei Eisen kann nicht mehr... Einfach... Also Eisen plus Eisen braucht Energie. Das heißt jetzt, die äußeren Hüllen erhitzen sich, starten neue Kernreaktionen, die einfach Kernen nach draußen wegpushen. Die Gravitation pusht aber andere Hüllen nach innen. Also es treffen sich wirklich, es sind Kernreaktionen, es treffen sich Kernen mit Kernen. Also die leichten wollen nach draußen, die schweren wollen nach innen. Und dadurch entstehen eben diese so große Drucks, dass auf einmal nicht mehr übrig bleibt. Und man muss eben von dieser großen, man nennt das Explosion, weil der Stern das nicht mehr zusammenhält. Jetzt was übrig bleibt.
Und das ist dann der Moment, wo die Supernova stattfindet?
Und was hinten bleibt, ist einfach ein kleines Teil von Kärntematerie, die so groß rotiert, die so stark rotiert, weil das ist Erhaltung.
Also jetzt überstrichst du gerade diesen großartigen Moment einer Supernova. Also ich meine, da geht es ja richtig zur Sache.
Ich weiß. Also man kann sagen, Star Wars bei Rogue One. Also der General meinte, wir haben, das war bezüglich des Death Star, wir haben jetzt eine Leistung, ein Power, der keiner im Universum je gesehen hat. Also man kann das dann nachrechnen. Ich hab das einfach gemacht. Wie groß ist die Leistung, die das Death Star hat. Also das ist eine Trivialität. Kann ich das kurz erzählen? Der hat überhaupt nicht mit Neutronensterne zu tun. Doch, doch. Partiell. Also man sieht in der Nummer, was ist das? Episode 4, das ist der erste von der 3er, der Neue Hoffnung. Genau. Wie das Death Star Alderaan zerstört. Und jetzt Alderaan, wenn man wirklich sich die Szene guckt, sieht Alderaan wie ein Photoshop von der Erde. Das ist wirklich, es sieht wie die Erde aus. Und man kann ausrechnen, wie viel Energie brauche ich, um die Erde zu zerstören. Gut, wir haben vier fundamentale Kräfte, aber was eigentlich die Erde zusammenhält, ist die Gravitation. Also ich kann einfach nachrechnen, wie viel Energie brauche ich, um ein kleines Stück von der Erde bis zum Unendlich rauszunehmen. Und das sagt mir Newton. Es ist eine kleine Teil, es geht wie G, große Gravitation, konstante. Und dann kommt die Masse von einem kleinen Teil, die ich wegreißen will, die Masse von der Erde, geteilt durch Radius. Das ist die Energie.
Also wie viel Energie brauche ich um die Erde?
Um ein kleines Stück rauszunehmen. Um die Erde zu zerstören, brauche ich einfach jeder einzelne Stück rauszunehmen. Mache ich eine Summe. Und da komme ich zu 10 auch, jetzt muss ich denken, bevor ich das vergesse, kann ich das nachgucken, komme ich zu einer X. Es ist um die 10 noch 37, 10 noch 40 Joule. Um die Leistung zu wissen, muss ich einfach Energie durch Zeit. Also ich dividiere durch die 2 Sekunden, bleibt sowieso groß. Jetzt gucke ich mich die Leuchtkraft einer Supernova-Explosion. Und das ist ein Millionen mal diese Zahl. Das heißt im Prinzip, als der General in Star Wars meinte, diese Leistung, diese Power hat keiner im Universum gesehen. Ich meinte, doch, das ist dann sehr so. Wenn diese Galaxie je weiter weg, das ist, ich weiß es nicht, aber sicherlich gehört zu diesem Universum, da hat diesem Universum sicherlich einige Supernova-Explosionen gesehen, die viel mehr Leuchtkraft haben als das Star in Star Wars.
Aber vielleicht bezog er sich nur auf das, was irgendwie Menschen oder wie auch immer gebaut hat.
Das ist einer der, ja, der Prichard hat einmal gesagt, it's still magic even if you know how it works. Ja, also selbst wenn man weiß, wie zu diesen Explosionen kommen kann, ist das wirklich unglaublich, was man da heutzutage beobachten kann und was man heutzutage sieht, ist das einfach, was übrig geblieben ist von so einer gigantischen Explosion. Und ja, das kommt immer in der Geschichte vom Leben und Tod einer Stern sehr kurz vor, weil das ist sozusagen eine Stufe in der Mitte, bevor man zum Tod kommt. Das sei es schwarzes Loch oder Neutronstern, wobei ich der Meinung bin, ein Neutronstern ist ein lebendes Objekt und kein schwarzes Loch. Aber das ist sicherlich einer der größte Ereignisse im Universum überhaupt. Und da werden übrigens, da könnte ich mal auch was sagen bezüglich Kernphysik, in so einer Explosion werden alle Elementen erzeugt, die schwerer als Eisen sind. Weil eigentlich, wenn man immer wieder sagt, Sterne produzieren alles bis Eisen, da fragt man sich, wie haben wir bitte Blei auf der Erde und wie haben wir bitte Gold? Also wenn man einfach die Verteilung von den Elementen im Sonnensystem guckt, da gehen wir die ganze Strecke bis es nicht mehr geht. Also bis zu dem schwersten, ich mag immer das Beispiel Gold, weil das ist fast am Ende. Und man sieht, wie wenig Gold im Solarsystem gibt im Vergleich zu Kohlenstoff. Und dann kann man sagen, das ist der Grund, warum Gold so viel kostet. Wir haben so wenig. Und wenn man immer wieder über Sterne redet, da stelle ich immer den Studierenden die Frage, kommt euch irgendwas nicht komisch vor? Und kann er sagen, doch, eigentlich schon, dass man in Sternen nicht bis zum Eisen, also in dieser lebenden Phase, nur bis zum Eisen produzieren kann. Was danach kommt, gehen wir davon aus, dass das eben während dieser, das dauert einen nicht. Eine Supernova-Explosion dauert ein paar Sekunden. Wenn man mit den Millionen Jahren Leben eines Sterns einfach vergleiche, ist das nichts. Und in dieser Kernreaktion von Kernen, die runterfallen, Kernen, die rausgehen, sind Kernreaktionen, werden alle anderen Elementen produziert. Übrigens, das Apropos Supernova kommen ganz kurz vor. Da kann ich stundenlang auch über Supernova reden. Das habe ich eben bei meiner Doktorarbeit gemacht.
Ja, bleiben wir ruhig nochmal kurz bei diesem Moment. Also um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, wir haben also normale Sterne, wie die Sonne, so herkömmliche Sterne, die sind durch Kernfusion in der Lage, so ziemlich alles zu erzeugen. Aber bei allem, was schwerer ist als Eisen, ist Schluss. Das kann die normale Kernfusion nicht erzeugen. Ist dann der Stern ein bisschen größer?
Ne, aufpassen, aufpassen, damit wir uns einfach verstehen. Ich kann einen Kern vom Eisen und eine andere Kern vom Eisen zusammenbringen. Eine Fusion kann stattfinden, ich brauche aber Energie. Wie ein Stern funktioniert, ist das Überfusion erzeugt Energie. Also E gleich mc². Ich muss dafür sorgen, dass meine Endprodukt leichter ist als die beiden ursprüngliche zusammen kommenden Kernen, sodass ich Energie freilasse. Eisen plus Eisen, also man sieht das, das ist wie eine Art Parabola. Das ist praktisch die Bindungsenergie, also was einen Kern zusammenhält. Das wird immer kleiner, kleiner, kleiner. Das Minimum ist beim Eisen und dann geht es größer. Heißt, dass ab dem Punkt, wenn ich eine Fusion machen kann, brauche ich Energie von draußen. Was machen wir, wenn wir Schwerionenforschung machen? Wir bringen ein Eisen plus ein Eisen zusammen. Wir pushen Energie. Ein Beschleuniger braucht Energie. Und dann kann ich die zusammenbringen. Aber es ist nicht, dass Energie frei wird. Und das ist der Grund, warum der Endpunkt des Lebens ein Sterneisen ist. Es ist nicht, dass Eisen nicht zusammen fusionieren kann. Kann das doch.
Aber der Stern ist nicht in der Lage, die Energie aufzubrechen.
Das ist der Grund, warum während eines Supernova kann ich schweren Elementen produzieren. Weil wenn ich so eine Leuchtkraft habe, die das Death Star vom Darth Vader ein Kinderspiel ist, dann habe ich Energie, die da ist. Und die kann ich doch nutzen, Eisen plus Eisen zusammenzubringen zum irgendwas Schwerer.
Das heißt, Millionen Jahre lang hat dieser Stern vor sich hingeschienen und es kam nicht mehr raus als Eisen. Und dann fällt irgendwie alles zusammen. Die Energie durch den Druck wird einfach so groß, dass innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden auf einmal alle möglichen anderen Elemente, die wir kennen. Und ich weiß nicht, gibt es eigentlich eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es noch irgendein Element da draußen gibt, was wir auf der Erde nicht haben?
Ja, alle exotischen Kern. Die können wir jetzt, wir sind so gut auf der Erde, by the way, dass wir diese Kerne im Labor produzieren können. Das ist, was wir exotische oder radioaktive Kerne nennen. Was macht ein exotischer Kern? Der ist eben nicht normal. Das heißt, er hat entweder unglaublich viel mehr Protonen als Neutronen oder er hat viel mehr Neutronen als Protonen. Das heißt, er ist nicht stabil. Der ist nicht wie Kohlenstoff, der bleibt Kohlenstoff-12, bleibt Kohlenstoff-12. Wir nutzen Kohlenstoff-12, um Dinge zu datieren. Das heißt, ein Kohlenstoff-12 bleibt ein Kohlenstoff-12 sein ganzes Leben lang. Wenn wir andere Kerne, die viel mehr Neutronen oder Protonen haben, nehmen wir als typisches Beispiel Kohlenstoff-12, das ist ein sehr stabiles Kern, ich kann aber auch Kohlenstoff-16 haben. Das ist sehr radioaktiv, der hat viel mehr Neutronen als Protonen. Wir können die jetzt im Labor erzeugen, das kann eine Supernova auch umsonst. Nur wir messen die nicht, weil dann irgendwann zerfallen. Aber das ist einer der Gründe, warum zum Beispiel auf der anderen Seite des Rheins jetzt an der neue Beschleunigeranlage diese Facility gebaut wird, um radioaktive Kernen zu untersuchen. Weil die sagen uns auch, wie diese Kerne gehen, nach drinnen können gehen, nach draußen in eine Supernova, welche Kerne können überhaupt zustande kommen. Heißt das, was ist der verrückteste, instabilste Form vom Kernen, die das Universum schafft? Wo brechen alle die Naturgesetze, die wir wissen, komplett zusammen, dass das nicht mehr machbar ist? Das heißt, warum reden wir jetzt über exotische Kerne? Jetzt hab ich das Waden verloren.
Ich wollte eigentlich wissen, es gibt diese, die schnell wieder zerfallen, aber gibt es noch irgendwelche stabilen Kerne, die vielleicht irgendwo in einer Supernova entstanden sind, die wir noch gar nicht hier haben?
Nein, also wir gehen davon aus, dass der, sagen wir so, kann man über die Großmutter, wobei Stern ist auf Deutsch männlich, es ist der Stern, nicht der Stern. Na gut, das heißt der ursprüngliche Großvater, dann ist ein Großvater, nicht eine Großmutter auf italienisch, ist die Stern, eine Stern war und 80% der Atomen in unserem Solarsystem von einer Sternen entstanden sind, die ungefähr 80 mal größer als unsere Sonne war. Und jetzt messen wir die Verteilung von den Elementen in unserem Sonnensystem. Es gibt keine stabilen Kerne, die wir nicht kennen. Wir wissen nicht, wie viele instabilen Kerne überhaupt möglich sind. Und das ist der Grund, warum wir solche Anlage bauen.
Okay, na gut, aber bleiben wir bei den stabilen. Also wir haben einen großen Stern, unter anderem der, der hier irgendwann mal in der Nähe explodiert ist, aus dem das Sonnensystem dann letztendlich sich wieder neu geformt hat. Es kommt zu dieser Supernova. Alles Mögliche wird produziert. Im Idealfall irgendwie auch wirklich alles Mögliche. Also es müssen alles Stabilmögliche. Bleibt dann auch entsprechend über. Das heißt, der Großteil der Materie, die in diesem Stern versammelt war, geht mit der Supernova einfach wieder ins Universum. Was bleibt über?
Ja, das ist die gute Frage. Was ist dieser Stern, der übrig bleibt? Also sozusagen wir wissen, wenn man gemessen hat, dass hinter dieser Supernova eine Neutron-Stern ist. Und was man modellieren konnte, ist dieser ganze dynamische Prozess, die einem nichts dauert, wo Kerne oder wo Elektronen in den Kernen hineingepresst werden und und und. In dieser ganzen Prozess ist es so, dass auf einmal ist die Energie einfach, sagen wir so, einfach verbraucht. Und da bleibt irgendwas hinten. Es ist wirklich, wenn man es will, es ist die gleiche Frage, die man stellen kann, ja, wenn das Ganze so explodiert ist, warum bleibt ein schwarzes Loch? Warum bleibt, was bleibt? Auch zu sagen, es bleibt einem nichts. Es ist auch so ein bisschen komisch als Frage de facto, wenn durch diese Explosion von Material immer noch mehr als vier Solarmasse bleiben, was bleibt, ist ein schwarzes Loch. Also was ist sozusagen das Mechanismus, und da kenne ich mich nicht aus, das dafür sorgt, dass diese Explosion mir ein nichts lässt, nur weil ich so viel Masse noch übrig habe. Also der Punkt ist, wie viel Masse schaffe ich, mit dieser 1044 Joule einfach rauszufliegen. Und was bleibt noch übrig?
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen vom Verhältnis her? Also wie viel Prozent geht weg, und wie viel bleibt über für den Neutronenstern?
Also es fliegt mehr als 70-80 Prozent weg.
So. Und jetzt sind ja Neutronensterne quasi so verhinderte schwarze Löcher. Also die haben so eine Menge Masse, und sie pressen auch alles extrem eng zusammen.
Das ist eine schöne Definition. Verhinderte schwarze Löcher finde ich genial. Okay, ich muss das benutzen, ich finde das gut.
So kommt mir das gerade vor. Ja, ist so. Wäre es ein bisschen mehr gewesen, wäre es so schwer, dass es in sich zusammenfällt. Aber das tut es ja irgendwie nicht.
Und jetzt ist einer der spannenden Fragen in dieser Forschung ist eben, was ist die kleinste Masse, die wir messen können? Ein schwarzes Loch? Da gibt es jetzt neue Beobachtungen von unterschiedlichen schwarzen Löchern. Man hofft jetzt, dass durch auch dieses neues Feld, dass jetzt ähnlich Daten liefert, die Gravitationswellen, man viel mehr schwarze Löcher beobachten kann, immer in Pan, aber immerhin, es macht Statistik, zweimal jedes Mal. Man einfach herausfinden kann, ob eine Grenze gibt an Masse, die ein schwarzes Loch haben kann. Wir dachten, dass eine Grenze... Genau. Wir dachten, es gab eine Grenze für die Masse, eine Neutronenstern. Wir dachten uns, 1,5, 1,7, 2... Über den letzten 5 oder 6 Jahren sind... Der Solarmassen. Sonnenmassen, Entschuldigung. Über den letzten 5 Jahren haben wir Neutronensterne gemessen, die bis zu 2,7 Sonnenmassen haben. Irgendwie muss man herausfinden, wenn man einfach verstehen will, warum in einem Fall und nicht in dem anderen, muss man einfach herausfinden, ist das einfach, ja, by chance, dass sozusagen, also vieles ist im Universum, also wenn wir jetzt zurückkommen auf Entstehung eines Sterns, ist Instabilität. Also ist das einfach eine Instabilität, die dafür sorgt, dass das eine Neutronenstern bleibt und die andere sich in ein schwarzes Loch entwickelt, oder ist irgendeine physikalische Gesetz da, die gegebenenfalls aus der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie herzuleiten wäre, weil das ist Schwerkraft de facto. Oder, und das wissen wir im Moment nicht, also wo geht das und das ist einer der Gründe, warum man immer neue Mischen hat bei Messung von Massen von Neutronensternen, ist einfach, damit man das immer präziser messen kann. Welche sind die Grenzen, bis um welchen Punkt kann ein Stern immer noch Stern bleiben? Selbst wenn man diese Neutronen davor hat, bleibt ein Stern. Und in einem anderen Fall, es wird blach, schwarz und es wird ein Loch.
Vielleicht sollte man das an der Stelle nochmal erklären, weil wir das jetzt so ein bisschen voraussetzen. Ein schwarzes Loch ist, wenn so viel Masse zusammenkommt, dass die Gravitation, die von dieser Masse ausgeht, so stark ist, dass selbst das Licht gebeugt wird. Deswegen ist eigentlich die Bezeichnung, man beobachtet ein schwarzes Loch.
Ist schon falsch per Definition.
Ist ein bisschen verwirrend, weil man beobachtet ja eigentlich nicht das schwarze Loch selber, sondern eigentlich nur noch den Bereich drumherum, den man aber erkennen kann, weil eben diese Krümmung des Lichtes wie so eine Linse sozusagen auch beobachtbar ist. Wenn ich das jetzt eben richtig verstanden habe, ist noch nicht vollkommen klar, ob es jetzt da sozusagen einen klar definierten Masse-Grenzwert gibt, wo man sagen kann, wenn so viele Massen zusammenkommen, dann ist es ein schwarzes Loch und wenn das kurz unterschritten wird, dann ist es ein Neutronenstern. Oder ob dieser übergangliche in gewisser Hinsicht auch fließend ist, weil er noch von anderen Prozessen unter Umständen abhängt. Was weiß ich, dass in diesem Neutronenstern noch irgendwelche Kräfte walten, die quasi noch mal gegenhalten und in irgendeiner Form dieses Zusammenfallen in einem schwarzen Loch verhindern.
Und diese Kräfte haben einen Namen. Das ist die starke Kraft. Das ist die Wechselwirkung, der eben die Kerne zusammenhält, bzw. die Quarks in einen Nukleon und die Nukleonen in einem Kern.
Also starke Kernkraft, eine der vier Grundkräfte.
Genau. Und das ist, wo die Astronomie oder die Kosmologie zusammen mit der Kernphysik sich trifft. Weil, jetzt muss ich einen kleinen Bogen schaffen. Wir wissen, was übrig bleibt bei einem Neutronenstern ist reine Kernmaterie. Wir wissen nicht, in welche Form. Die Theoretiker nennen das Pasta. Andere Theoretiker nennen das Quark Stars. Also, die denken, dass der Kern, eine Neutronenstern, nur als Quarks, als freie Quarks, einfach da ist. Andere denken, dass drinnen ist eine Kernmaterie so exotisch, dass wir das überhaupt noch nicht hier im Labor reproduziert haben. De facto ist aber Kernmaterie.
Aber nicht mehr Atomkerne, wie wir sie kennen. Sondern alles sozusagen so zusammengedrückt, das ist sozusagen nur noch so eine Melange, so ein Plasma von...
Und bleiben wir jetzt bei dem Adjektiv gedruckt. Es geht darum, wie viel kann ich Kernmaterie drucken. Und das ist, was technisch Kompressibilität heißt. Wir erkennen die Kompressibilität von Wasser. Also Flüssigkeiten haben ihre Kompressibilität. Gasen kann man squeezen, wie man will. Und so weiter und so fort. Die Kernmaterie ist eine Materie. Das sind nur Kerne. Ich muss mich fragen, wie viel kann ich das komprimieren? Und genauso in dem Fall von Wasser oder Gas, wenn ich über solche Eigenschaften wie Kompressibilität rede, rede ich über die Zustandsgleichung. Die Zustandsgleichung vom Wasser kennt jedes Kind. Das Wasser bei 0°C ist Eis. Es kocht bei 100°C. Es hat diese Form. Die Temperatur als Funktion von der Dichte geht ein bisschen hoch. Dann wird es flach. Das ist, wo Flüssigkeit und Gas zusammen sind. Wenn das Wasser kocht und bloppt, dann ist es nur Gas. Das Ziel ist, diese Kurve auch für die Kernmaterie zu machen. Glücklicherweise kann ich nicht die Kernmaterie so ohne Weiteres auf Kochen bringen. Ich will aber einfach wissen, was sind die fundamentale Eigenschaften von Kernmaterie? Wie viel kann ich das komprimieren? Wie viel kann ich das erhitzen? Was kommt, wenn das unglaublich hohe Temperaturen sind? Und das ist der Grund, warum man im Laborn unter der Erde auf die gleiche Frage eine Antwort finden will, wie die Astronomen die Neutronsterne durch Radiosignalen oder Ähnliches beobachten. Am Ende kommt daraus, dass wir mit der gleiche Materie zu tun haben und wir die gleiche Gleichung finden wollen, also die gleiche Kurve. Und diese Kurve wird uns sagen, was ist die größte Masse, die eine Neutronstern haben kann. Weil, wenn ich herausfinde, dass ich kann Materie so und so viel komprimieren, dann weiß ich, wenn ich drei Solarmassen, drei Sonnenmasse habe, dann kann ich das komprimieren. Das heisst, ich muss irgendwo im Universum, es wird nur eine Frage der Zeit, eine drei Sonnenmasse Neutronsterne beobachten können. Wenn ich aber herausfinde, dass Kernmaterie kann zu komprimieren, ja, aber nicht bis zum diesen Punkt, sondern ein bisschen weniger, dann weiß ich, dass die maximale Masse von einer Neutronstern wird 2,7 Sonnenmassen sein. Und dann weiß ich, ok, alles was schwerer ist, wird zum Schwarzes Loch. Und dann wissen sind wir ein Stück weiter in diesem, sagen wir so, Verständnis, wie entwickeln sich Sterne, wenn sie sich ihrem Tod nähern, sei es Schwarzes Loch oder Neutronstern. Und das ist, wo eben auch so unterschiedliche Bereiche wie Astronomie, Kosmologie und Kernphysik die Leute sich treffen. Weil was ich im Labor messe, muss irgendwann zusammengebracht werden mit was die Astronomen einfach an Massen einfach gemessen haben. Das typisches Beispiel war eine Theorie, die bei der Kernphysiker sehr stark verbreitet war. Die hatte einfach vorhergesagt, es muss ein ganz komisches Teilchen geben, die wir nicht gemessen haben, aber es gibt dieses Teilchen und das wird alles mögliches erklären. Und glücklicherweise, wenn dieses Teilchen gegeben hätte, dann wäre die Kompressibilität von Kernmaterie so, dass wir keine 2,5 Sonnenmasse Neutronenstern hätten beobachten können. Da kamen die Astronomen mit ihrer wunderschönen Messung mit Shapiro-Delay. Die haben einfach eine Paar von einer Neutronenstern, man nennt das mit einem Kompagnon. Wenn man zwei Objekte hat, die eine um den anderen rotieren, kann man diese Radiosignal von den rotierenden Pulsen mit einem Delay, einer Verspätung beobachten, abhängig davon, wo der Kompagnon steht in Bezug zu Erde. Und von dieser Messung, das ist hochpräzise, die könnten die Masse von dieser Neutronenstern einfach bestimmen. Da stellte sich heraus, es war eine 2,5 Sonnenmasse.
Was nicht gegangen wäre, wenn es dieses Teilchen gibt.
Genau, das heißt, die Theorie war tot, auf einmal. Also eine Theorie in Kernphysik, komplett rausgekickt, wegen einer Messung von den Astronomen. Nicht schlecht. Das war optimal, höchste effizient.
Hätte ja auch sein können, dass sie falsch gemessen haben.
Nee, nee, also sagen wir so, es gibt einige Messungen und das sind die Astrophysiker sehr fair. Also wenn die zum Beispiel sagen, was für Radien können Neutronensternen haben, da haben die keine präzise Messungen. Das heißt, die geben Fehler Balken, die sehr groß sind. Also die sagen 7 Kilometer plus minus 3. Man lacht sich tot. Man muss sich aber auch ausdenken, was das überhaupt bedeutet, so eine Messung durchzuführen. Bei den Massen, die haben unglaublich neue und sehr präzisere Methode entwickelt, da die Messung ist 2,5 plus minus 0,1 oder plus minus 0,07 Sonnenmassen. Und der Unterschied jetzt ist so klein, dass die Theorie sowieso aus wäre. Mit dieser Theorie hätte man einfach gesagt, die maximale Masse, eine Neutronenstern, kann 1,7 Solarmassen sein. Weil die Kompressibilität der Kernmaterie war nicht so groß. Das heißt, ich hätte nicht so viel Kernmaterie zusammendrucken können und das immer noch ein stabiles System dadurch erzeugen. Das heißt, was wir wissen, man sagt, dass Kernmaterie soft ist. Man kann das komprimieren. Wir wissen nicht, wie viel kann man das komprimieren. Und das ist, warum wir immer noch forschen.
Wenn ich jetzt höre, Kernmaterie, also wenn ich jetzt von dem normalen Standardmodell eines Atoms ausgehe, da haben wir halt so den Kern mit Protonen und Neutronen und dann in größerem Abstand kreisen oder die kreisen ja nicht wirklich, aber da befinden sich auf jeden Fall Elektronen drum herum. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt so von so einem normalen Stück Holz ausgehen, wie der Tisch, an dem wir jetzt hier gerade sitzen, dann sind die Atome zwar recht dicht beieinander, aber so in der Dimension eines Atomkerns sind zwischen zwei Kernen relativ große Abstände. Da ist es relativ weit weg. In dieser Neutronensternsituation, wo das alles enorm zusammengepresst wird, sind da überhaupt noch Elektronen?
Nein. Die sind alle draußen.
Die sind alle draußen, weil denen ist das auch zu heiß.
Also ursprünglich der Name Neutronenstern war so, weil man dachte an der Oberfläche sind nur Neutronen. Und was man drinnen hat sind Quarks oder sowas. Heute wissen wir, dass eigentlich, wenn das nur Neutronen wären, die würden nicht einfach gebunden sein. Die Theoretiker überlegen sich diese, man nennt das wirklich Pasta und die haben eben Lasagne oder irgendwas, die nennen das wirklich so. Also das ist kein Scherz. Ich fühle mich fast zu Hause. Wenn man einfach diese unterschiedlichen Pastas von Kernen, also wie bei welchen Strukturen einfach Kernen zusammenkommen können, die einfach stabil sind immer noch. Indem ich die zusammenpresse. Also wie kann ich Proton und Neutron so zusammenbringen? Sind die immer noch Proton und Neutron zusammen? Reden wir immer noch über Kerne oder reden wir über eben Materie? Also es ist, wenn man will, das Gleiche. Also Wasser ist eine Form von Materie. Flüssigkeit ist eine Materie. Jetzt aber Wasser eigentlich weiß ich, das sind Moleküle. Also was ist Materie? Sind die Moleküle oder die Flüssigkeit? Und eigentlich, wenn ich die Moleküle gucke, sind eigentlich Atomen dabei. Also was ist die? Nur bei Wasser, da können wir das wirklich messen. Und dann alle die feine Unterschiede abhängig von den Skalen, an denen wir das Wasser beobachten, einfach unterschiedliche Eigenschaften von den Materie zu untersuchen. Bei Kernen ist schwieriger. Wir können nicht Kernen einfach berühren. Also es geht einfach darum, und das ist zum Beispiel ein Teil auch der Forschung, die in Genf am Large-Adren-Collider einfach gemacht wird, man schießt einfach zwei Bleikerne bei höchster Energie einfach und lässt die zusammenprallen. Und dann guckt, was passiert, wenn ich mit der größte Kraft, die ich auf der Welt gebaut habe, das ist das Large-Adren-Collider, was kriege ich als Materie da? Und dann, was man herausgefunden hat, ist, was man Quark-Gluon-Plasma nennt. Also, das sind die Quarks, die elementaren Konstituenten, die die Bausteine, wie wir die im Standard-Modell kennen, mit den Gluonen, das sind die Wechselwirkung- Teilchen der starke Wechselwirkung, in eine Plasma. Und wir benutzen das Wort Plasma, weil es sich wie ein Plasma einfach benimmt, aber aus reiner Kernmaterie. Wobei, vielleicht ist Kernmaterie das falsche Wort, man sollte es nennen stark wechselwirkende Materie und dann hätte man das einfach, weil wenn man, wir reden in, sagen wir so, Jargon über Kernmaterie und wir wissen, was Kernmaterie heißt, es sind keine Kerne. Im Prinzip sollte man, wenn man das wirklich wissenschaftlich kohärent darstellen wollte, sollte man sagen, starke wechselwirkende Materie. Also es ist die Materie, wie wir sie kennen, wo aber die einzige Kraft, die eine Rolle spielt, ist die starke Wechselwirkung. Und das ist irgendwas, an dem wir tagtäglich nicht daran gewohnt sind. Weil was wir tagtäglich erleben, de facto ist entweder Schwerkraft oder Elektromagnetismus. Die starke Wechselwirkung.
Und Radioaktivität, auch wenn wir sie nicht sehen. Man kann es sich zumindest vorstellen.
Ja, aber sozusagen mit der starke Wechselwirkung haben wir keine Berührungspunkte.
Es ist die Kraft, die das Innerste zusammenhält.
Ja, genau.
Um es nochmal kurz aus meiner Perspektive zusammenzufassen. Also dieses extrem zusammengedrückte Ding sind quasi Atome ihrer Elektronen und ihrer eigentlichen Atomstruktur befreite Kerne, die sich näher kommen, als sie das im normalen Zustand, also dem, was wir als normal empfinden, zumindest so nah zusammenkommen wie sonst eben gar nicht. Dadurch natürlich eine extreme Hitze haben und wo unter Umständen auch so diese Einteilung in du bist ein Proton und du bist ein Neutron auch schon gar keine Rolle mehr spielt, weil sich eigentlich auf der Ebene darunter abspielt, nämlich bei den Quarks, derer es glaube ich sechs gibt, wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere, die sozusagen in unterschiedlichen Konstellationen sich eben wie ein Neutron oder wie ein Proton dann eben verhalten oder diese ausbilden. Man hat sozusagen eigentlich so eine Quarksuppe, die nur noch zusammengehalten wird, eben durch die Kraft, die an der Ebene, auf der Ebene eben eine Rolle spielt, nämlich die starke Wechselwirkung, das, was Atome zusammenhält, das alles miteinander verrührt. Also man hat halt nicht irgendwie einen großen Sack von Erdnüssen, sondern man hat quasi Nutella. Das ist nur noch so eine einzige Paste eben, genauso eine engstmögliche Vermischung dieses Materials, was wahrscheinlich unfassbar heiß ist in diesem Zustand. Das ist quasi oder vermutlich oder weiß man das, das ist das, was den Neutronenstern, den man jetzt wahrscheinlich anders nennen müsste, aber nun heißt er nun mal so, im Wesentlichen ausmacht. Die Sonne wird groß, die Sonne wird heiß, sie fusioniert Millionen Jahre vor sich hin. Irgendwann ist Schluss mit lustig, alles explodiert, 80 Prozent fliegt weg und am Ende bleibt irgendwie so ein großer Nutella-Klumpen von Kernmaterie und ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht stark genug, um alles Licht auch noch mit reinzufressen und als schwarzes Loch beobachtbar zu sein. Sondern es ist irgendwie so ein Ding, was das Licht weitgehend in Ruhe lässt. Das hat ja trotzdem eine extreme Gravitation. Theoretisch würde es auch einen Linseneffekt ausbilden, was man nicht beobachtet. Aber es ist natürlich so mega klein, dass das gar nicht zu sehen ist.
Ja, der Punkt ist einfach Folgendes, dass in unserer Nähe haben wir keine Neutronenstern beobachten können. Also man hört sie. Und deshalb sage ich, das habe ich über Schwangesang. Man hört sie.
Man weiß, sie sind da, aber man sieht sie nicht.
Man sieht sie nicht. Und ich denke, bei der großen Entfernung, es sei denn, wir schaffen Hubble so dieser Deep Space Hubble, das neue Upgrade vom Hubble, das ein bisschen tiefer im Universum gucken kann. Da wären der Unterschiede in Lansing so klein, um zehn Kilometer oder um sieben Kilometer, man würde die nicht beobachten können. Es ist alles richtig, außer zwei Dinge. Erstmal, das wird nicht unserer Sonne passieren, weil du hast gesagt, unsere Sonne. Da sag ich, unsere Sonne nicht. Und zweitens, wir wissen, dass drinnen so ist, wir gehen davon aus. Die Neutronensterne sind so ein spannendes Thema, weil wir immer noch dabei sind, herauszufinden, was ist da drin? Was ist möglich? Und das ist der Grund, warum so viele Forscher auch in unterschiedlichen Bereichen, weil Large Atom Collider sind Teilchenphysiker, ich bin Kernastrophysikerin, da gibt es Astronomen, dann gibt es Theoretiker, da gibt es Kosmologen, einfach herauszufinden, was ist dann möglich überhaupt?
Angenommen, uns würde jetzt Gravitation nichts ausmachen und wir könnten uns auch noch beliebig schnell irgendwo hinbewegen. Und wir würden jetzt zu einem Neutronenstern fliegen. Und wir würden nicht sofort zerplatzen. Und uns sozusagen in die Nähe begeben können. Was würde man denn vermutlich sehen? Würde man da Glüter was? Ist doch irre heiß irgendwie. Ist das dann im Prinzip auch hell, aber es ist nur so klein, dass wir das nicht wirklich als Stern sehen? Oder ist es einfach heiß, aber trotzdem schwarz? Ist das irgendwie glatt? Oder sieht das aus wie eine Kastanie? Was bewegt sich das? Oder liegt das auch einfach nur so rum?
Also es ist, da muss man sich das einfach überlegen, wie sieht ein Neutronenstern vom nah aus? Also es ist ein unglaublich, also erstmal, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, weil ich weiß, man kann nicht in der Nähe einen Neutronenstern kriegen. Naja, dem hab ich ja im Podcast nicht alles möglich.
Ist der glatt? Müsste der nicht extrem glatt sein, weil er so schwer ist? Ich meine, wenn da alles so mega zusammengedrückt wird, dann müsste das doch fast eine perfekte Kugel sein.
Der Punkt ist jetzt, ich muss mir das überlegen, wie sieht eines Objekts, der unglaublich stark geladen ist, weil die Magnetfelder, die da herrschen, sind unglaublich groß. Sieht das glatt aus, kann ich die Fläche, die Oberfläche von so einem Objekt wirklich sehen? Nach dem Motto, ist unsere Sonne glatt? Weil ich habe immer noch Klumpen von Materie, die einfach durch dieses starken Magnetfeld umherum gewogen sind. Also ist der Stern glatt? Also vermutlich, wenn diese Pasta-Zeug wirklich wahr ist, der Nutella-Stern. Nein, also die Oberfläche ist diese Pasta. Das ist so eine Art Krüste. Also genau, was ich immer als Beispiel nehme, das passt Nutella sehr gut, das passt unglaublich gut, sind die belgische Pralinen. Also eine Neutron-Sterne ist eine belgische Praline. So nehmen wir das im Moment an. Das heißt, ich habe eine Krüste, und das sind Kerne in dieser Pasta komischen Dingsform. Und dann drinnen ist einfach Nutella. Also ist diese Pasta flach? Ja, im Prinzip sollte diese Pasta so eine Art Kruste bauen, die flach ist. Aber sozusagen ruhig ist das auch nicht, weil da reden wir über sehr große Magnetfelder. Und noch dazu, es rotiert stark. Also es erzeugt Röntgenstrahlung, alles Mögliche, was wir über geladene Teilchen in sehr starke elektromagnetische Felder kennen. Also sind wir noch am Leben in der Nähe von den Neutron-Sternen? Was kann ich noch beobachten? Was man sicherlich beobachten kann, also wenn man so nah ist, ist, dass wirklich das Licht Bogen nimmt. Weil ich habe ein sehr schweres Objekt, das sicherlich den Raumzeit biegt. Das könnte ich auch sehen. Aber in der Zwischenzeit bin ich schon gefressen worden als Materie. Einfach ausgesaugt, wie normalerweise beim Rote Riesen der Fall ist, der nicht so nahe ist, aber nah genug, um ausgesaugt zu werden. Aber das wäre mein schönes Traum. Was passiert, was sehe ich, wenn ich in der Nähe? Es gibt viele Simulationen heutzutage. Die kann man auch beim NASA finden. Die zeigen, wie eine Neutronenstern aussieht. Manche haben auch so eine Art von Jet, so Strahlung, die an beiden Polen nach draußen geht. Also sozusagen Umdruck von dieser Inneren, die wir nicht wissen, was das überhaupt ist, rauszukriegen. Und die werden dann in dem Magnetfeld einfach gebogen. Aber wie das wirklich ist, wissen wir nicht. Aber es wäre eine schöne Reise ohne Zurückticket.
Jetzt gab es ja vor einiger Zeit, vor kurzer Zeit, relativ kurzer Zeit, den ersten Nachweis von Gravitationswellen. Auch Raumzeit hat sich ja hier in einem ausführlichen Gespräch dieses Themas gewidmet und dort konnte ja dann die Kollision zweier...
Zwei schwarze Löcher.
Zwei schwarze Löcher nachgewiesen werden. Und man hatte diese wunderbaren mathematischen Modelle in den Jahren schon zuvor, wo sehr klare Vorhersagen gemacht wurden, wie das dann wohl aussehen würde, wenn man denn eine Gravitationswelle messen würde. Und oh wunder, die erste Messung hat dann auch genau so etwas gefunden und es war extrem deckungsgleich. Wird man vielleicht auch mit Gravitationswellen bei Neutronensternen etwas messen können, weil wenn die Dinge auch so super massiv sind, wäre ja auch die Kollision zweier Neutronensterne vorstellbar und gibt es da auch entsprechend...
Und das ist, was wir hoffen eigentlich. Weil das Merging von zwei Neutronensternen kann uns auch unglaublich viele Informationen eben bezüglich dieser, wie verhält sich diese Kernmaterie überhaupt uns geben. Es gibt schon Simulationen, wie das Signal von zwei Merging Neutronenster auszusehen hat und wie es sich ändert, abhängig davon Kompressibilität von Kernmaterie und und und. Und nicht in dieser normalen, normalen, also 1,8 Billionen Jahren her, zwei schwarze Löcher trafen sich, normal, egal, aber gut. Das war, als die letzte Pressemitteilung kam, dass Virgo auch Daten nimmt, habe ich auf Twitter, die Amerikaner waren als erste dran, der erste Merging würde nur ins USA gemessen, weil wie jeder gesagt hat, die Italiener waren gerade dabei Kaffee zu trinken und jetzt ist auch Virgo, das ist in Italien in der Nähe von Pisa, der andere Interferometer ist an und die haben jetzt beobachten können diese 1,8 Billionen Jahre her, wenn man das so sagen will, diese erneute Merging von zwei Schwarze Löcher. Und da habe ich mich auf Twitter mit einem Kollegen unterhalten und gesagt, eigentlich, da das schon das dritte Merging ist, wir gewöhnen uns langsam daran, aber man braucht nur die Pressemitteilung zu lesen. Das wie die Amerikaner sagen, das blow out my mind. Das ist so verrückt, was wir im Moment messen. Wir waren alle sehr enttäuscht, dass wieder mal nur zwei Schwarze Löcher waren. Weil es gab im Sommer stand ein Gerücht, der noch nicht gekillt worden ist. Endlich hat LIGO, mindestens ob das auch Virgo das gesehen hat, weiß ich nicht, das Merging von zwei Neutronensternen beobachten. Und jetzt der Signal, da waren wir von einer Gravitationswelle, kann man immer in drei Regionen einfach schneiden, das Pre-Merging, das Merging und das danach. Und jetzt bei den Neutronensternen, was unglaublich wichtig ist, ist der letzte Teil von diesem Signal, weil der und ein Teil davon auch den mittleren, weil der sagt uns, wie viel kann die Materie von zwei Neutronensternen zusammen komprimiert werden. Also das, was wir gern in unseren Laboren auch gern tun würden, also zwei Neutronensternen beschleunigen und gegeneinander prallen zu lassen und dann gucken, was entsteht für, also wie viel können sich die beiden einfach komprimieren.
Also es geht jetzt, um noch ein bisschen weiter ausholen, das Tolle daran, dass jetzt der dritte Gravitationswellen, also das dritte Gravitationswellen-Messgerät in Betrieb genommen worden.
Der zweite. Virgo ist der zweite.
Ja, aber LIGO besteht ja aus zwei Standorten.
Ja, ich weiß, aber man redet über LIGO einfach als Ganzes.
Ja, also ein dritten Standort.
Genau, ein dritten Standort.
Das erlaubt ja jetzt auch die Richtung. Genau, die Richtung und damit halt eine möglichst genaue Positionierung, so dass man ja theoretisch auch noch die Möglichkeit hätte, in dem Moment, wo die Welle gemessen wird, dass man relativ schnell mit allem, was in irgendeiner Form beobachten kann, dort hinschauen kann, weil wenn da irgendwas geknallt hat und da irgendwelche Strahlung in dem Moment aktiv wird, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit ja relativ hoch, dass man das dann auch beobachten kann. Dass man also irgendetwas misst, was eben jetzt nicht eine Gravitationswelle ist, sondern dass man in irgendeiner Form irgendwelche Röntgenblitze oder was auch immer davon ausgehen mag, auch noch messen kann. Wenn jetzt zwei, so, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, also würden wir jetzt eine Gravitationswelle messen, die in ihrer Kennlinie sagt, das ist ja jetzt kein schwarzes Loch, sondern das sind wahrscheinlich zwei Neutronensterne, die aufeinander geprahlt sind, dann könnte, würde jetzt, würde man nicht nur jetzt die Position daraus ablesen können, sondern man würde aus der Welle auch noch eine Information über die Kompressibilität von der Kernmaterie lernen.
So sagen die, die neuesten Rechnungen basierend auf allgemeine Relativitätstheorie, plus die Kernmaterie oder starke wechselwirkende Materie-Zustandsgleichung. Also wie viel kann ich das komprimieren, wie viel kann ich das erhitzen, dass in dem Moment, wenn ich die zweite ende, allgemeine Relativitätstheorie bleibt gleich, dann ändert sich dieser Signal. Das heißt, im Prinzip kann ich eben das gleiche nachmessen, was heutzutage über diese Multi-Messenger Astronomie einfach genannt wird, ich drehe mal Fermi und ich gucke mal, ob in die Richtung Positronen kommen oder irgendwas Ähnlicheres, sondern kann ich auch noch fundamentale Eigenschaften der Kernmaterie auch herauslesen können. Und das ist der Grund, warum wir alle Kernphysiker oder Neutronenstammphysiker sehr enttäuscht waren. Also es kamen wieder mal zwei schwarze Löcher. Ach du liebe, da mussten wir noch warten.
Langweilig. Also alle sitzen eigentlich gerade auf heißen Kohlen, kann man sagen. Also jederzeit könnte eine Botschaft kommen, jetzt haben wir halt mal was anderes gemessen. Ist denn das Signal, was man von so einer Kollision zweier Neutronensterne erwarten würde, auch ähnlich einfach zu messen, also einfach in Anführungsstrichen, also genauso einfach oder genauso schwer zu messen wie die schwarzen Löcher? Oder sind hier geringere Energien am Start, sodass die Auflösung der Gravitationswellen, Messgeräte unter Umständen noch gesteigert werden müsste?
Also die Hoffnung, und das ist, was beide LIGO- und GERGO-Kollaboration auch gesagt haben, das Merging von zwei Neutronensternen, wenn die schwer genug sind, das ist an der Grenze der Auflösung von beiden. Das heißt, die könnten das messen. Der Punkt, was ich mich frage, weil ich in Gravitationswellenphysik nicht so viel drin bin, ist einfach dadurch, wenn man, und das haben die super schön erklärt bei der unterschiedlichen Pressemitteilungen, die die gegeben haben, wenn zwei schwarze Löcher einfach kollidieren, dann wird viel Materie in Energie umgewandelt, immer eh gleich mc², und das in Welle umgesetzt. Jetzt der Punkt geht es darum, wie viel Energie in der Kollision frei wird, weil die Energie, die frei wird, sagt mir, wie viel Energie in Gravitationswellen dann zur Erde kommt. Und dann sag ich, ist das nicht für Neutronensterne einfach ein Loop? Weil wieder mal, wie viel Energie frei wird, hängt das davon ab, wie viel kann ich die komprimieren.
Das heißt, es könnte sein, dass zwei Neutronensterne aufeinandertreffen und dass gar keine Energie frei wird. Das heißt, dass einfach noch mehr Kompressibilität möglich ist und dieses einfach schlucken.
Das heißt, im Prinzip, ja zum Beispiel, sich zu einem schwarzen Loch entwickeln, ja. Das heißt, im Prinzip verstehe ich, also ich verstehe es wohl und es scheint mir auch sehr vernünftig, diese neuesten Theorien, die sagen, ich sehe doch abhängig davon, wie stark komprimierbar meine Materie ist, eine Änderung im Signal. Ja, danke. Jetzt der Punkt ist, wenn da zu viel komprimierbar ist, kann es auch, also ich werde diese, also in der Theorie werde ich immer noch einen Signal sehen, aber es kann sein, dass das für die Auflösung von beide, also von alle drei, wie du willst, aber von LIGO und Virgo nicht genug ist, weil das an der Grenze, also wenn man einfach bedenkt, der erste bombastische Kollision, die haben eine Fraktion von einem Protonenradius auflösen müssen hier auf der Erde und da war viel Energie bis zum Vier-Sonnen-Massen-Energie frei. Das bleiben wir gespannt. Aber das wäre großartig. Aber es ist immer wahr, also das würde uns sagen, wie schwer zum Beispiel Neutronensterne überhaupt sehen können. Weil ich meine, im Prinzip, wenn wir irgendwas messen, das sagt uns, also schon die Tatsache, dass wir das messen, wird uns sagen, wird uns eine sozusagen, wie sagt man, upper limit, also zur Obergrenze zu, wie komprimierbar ist diesen Zeug, weil ich hab das gemessen. Das sagt mir auch, wie schwer können zwei Neutronensterne sein. Das sind, weil ich meine, wenn man einfach bedenkt, das, was wir zuletzt als Gravitationswelle gemessen haben, ist ein Ereignis von 1,8 Billionen Jahren. So was kommt, so eine Neutronensterne so weit weg können wir nicht messen. Das heißt, wir beobachten damit viel tiefer im Universum rein. Und vielleicht gibt es viel mehr Neutronensterne, als wir jetzt hier in der Nähe sozusagen beobachten, das heißt, hören könnten. Es sagt uns unglaublich viel. Und deshalb waren wir so, sagt uns, ihr habt das gemessen, bitte sagt uns, ihr habt das gemessen. Aber leider waren es zwei schwarze Löcher, wieder mal. Aber wir hoffen alle, dass das noch stattfinden wird.
Wenn jetzt, kann man das so sehen, dass quasi, also vielleicht kann man das so sehen, wir hatten das ja schon kurz angesprochen, aber es wäre ja durchaus möglich, dass eben so ein Neutronenstern so die Stufe kurz vor dem schwarzen Loch ist. Kann man sich das dann sozusagen so vorstellen, dass eigentlich in einem schwarzen Loch eigentlich so ein überdimensioneller Neutronenstern ist, dass sozusagen, ich meine, auch ein schwarzes Loch, wir sehen ja nur, was es mit der Umgebung tut, ja. Es gibt ja ja auch entsprechende Strahlung, die von einem schwarzen Loch ausgeht, die aber nicht aus dem schwarzen Loch herauskommt, sondern die quasi so ein Randeffekt des schwarzen Lochs ist. Wenn jetzt zwei Neutronensterne sich zusammentun und dann quasi in die kritische Masse zum schwarzen Loch hin überschreiten, dann wird quasi aus denen ein schwarzes Loch und ist ein schwarzes Loch ein überdimensioneller Neutronenstern? Ist in so einem schwarzen Loch auch nur Nutella oder ist das jetzt zu weit hergeholt?
Ich denke, das ist zu weit weg, weil ich meine, was ein alles, was wir schwarzes Loch, also der Hawkins hat unglaublich viel viel daran gearbeitet, eine Theorie der schwarzen Löcher zu entwickeln. Sagen wir so, was nach einem schwarzen Loch, schon die Aussage, was hinter einem schwarzen Loch ist, ist falsch. Da gibt es keine hinter einem schwarzen Loch. Also das ist nichts, das ist ein Nichts. Es ist eine sozusagen, wenn man das so, aber es ist wirklich salopp formuliert, es ist ein Riss in Raumzeit. Es gab so Science Fiction, man würde in ein schwarzes Loch fliegen und da sage ich, okay, da die Wissenschaftlerin in mir sagt, ach du lieber Gott, da wird man unendlich auseinandergenommen und das wird unendlich lang dauern. Das ist, was ich mir in einem schwarzen Loch mal vorstellen kann. Es ist einfach die ganze Zeit und Raum, wie wir sie kennen, die gelten in einem schwarzen Loch nicht. Das heißt, so zu denken, als ob man diese Form von einem schwarzen Loch hat und dann hinten ist ein Neutronenstern, da kriege ich das nicht hin. Also die Brücke kriege ich nicht hin.
Also meine Nutella-Philosophie, die hat auch ihre Grenzen. Kommen wir noch mal auf die Erde, wie man den jetzt eigentlich beobachtet. Also was sehen wir denn von einem Neutronenstern? Wir haben es ja so am Rande schon ein wenig ausgelotet. Da gibt es irgendwie Strahlung, man empfängt Röntgenstrahlung, Gammastrahlung, sehr hochenergetische Strahlung, die von diesen Neutronensternen an ihren Polen ausgesendet wird.
Das ist eigentlich eine der traurigsten Geschichten der Physik, also der Nobelpreis, der nie vergeben wurde, an dem Jocelyn Bell. Das ist, apropos Gender Equality in der Wissenschaft. Sie war Doktorandin und sie hatte die Aufgabe in ihrer Doktorarbeit, diese erste X-Ray-Anlage, da sieht man die Bilder, die waren wirklich sozusagen fast primitiv, mal zu rebooten, um einfach zu messen. Und da kamen die ersten Signalen und da hatte sie immer wieder diesen Peak. Und der Signal wurde LGM-1 genannt, wo das steht für Little Green Man. Und zwar die Idee war, das sind Extraterresten, die einfach versuchen mit uns zu reden, sie dachte das nicht, sie dachte es sei irgendein Problem mit der ganzen Anlage. Sie kamen zu ihrem Doktorvater und er meinte, du musst alles neu machen und so weiter. Also alles neu gebaut, alles neu getestet, alles neu kalibriert, kam wieder mal Little Green Man 1. Und da kam zusätzlich dazu eine andere, neue Signal bei einer anderen Frequenz. Und das nannte sie LGM-2, also Little Green Man 2. Sie ging zu ihrem Doktorvater und sagte, schau, ich hab alles Neues gemacht. Und da sehe ich nicht nur diese ursprüngliche Signal, da sehe ich auch diese neue hier. Und ihr Doktorvater war klug genug zu sagen, du misst gerade vermutlich Pulsaren. Weil die Theorie zum Neutronstern gab es schon. Und Pulsaren, man nennt die Pulsaren, weil die pulsieren. Weil man eben diese X-Ray-Signal nur eben in sehr bestimmten Frequenzabständen hört. Mit einer sehr bestimmten Frequenz. Und dann würde das Ganze veröffentlicht. Und der Nobelpreis hat sein Doktorvater mit anderen, die dann separat auch ähnliche Signale gemessen haben. Und die Jocelyn Bell hat nie den Nobelpreis bekommen. Wobei, das war ihr Forschung. Jetzt brennt es zu. Das ist, was wir messen. Und heutzutage haben wir sicherlich Antennen auf der Erde, die eine viel größere Akzeptanz haben als diese primitive Anlage, die die Jocelyn Bell einfach genutzt hat. Und das bekommen wir an Signalen. Und dann gibt es sozusagen, on the top of that, kann man auch mit diesen Signalen unterschiedliche Methoden entwickeln. Einer, der wird eben bei dieser sehr schweren Neutron-Stern genutzt, ist dieser Shapiro-Delay. Also man misst nicht nur die Frequenz von den Pulsar, sondern auch diese Verspätung, mit dem ein Signal auf der Erde kommt. Und man weiß, es ist eine Binary, also Neutron-Stern mit einem Kompagnon, und die einfach rotieren. Und dann kann man nicht nur die zum Beispiel Winkelgeschwindigkeit einfach bestimmen, sondern auch die Masse. Und das ist, was wir beobachten. Beobachten, wenn man so beobachtet.
Ja, man sieht es nicht, aber messen ist beobachten. Und wie häufig sind Neutronensterne?
Gibt es viele? Also bisher, jetzt würde ich ungern so eine Zahl auf dem Hut zaubern, aber ich denke, wir haben 40 gemessen. Es sind nicht viele. Wenn man einfach denkt, wie viele Trillionen und Trillionen von Sternen gibt, Neutronensterne sind zumindest, was wir beobachten können, sehr selten. Jetzt aber kann man sich auch fragen, schwarze Löcher sind selten. Und jetzt dank zu diesen Gravitationswellen haben wir innerhalb von 6 Monaten auf einmal 6 schwarze Löcher, so 2 jedes Mal, messen können. Kann man sich vielleicht die Frage stellen, vielleicht gibt es viel mehr Neutronensterne, nur die sind sehr alt. Also wenn man einfach denkt, das Lebenzyklus eines Sterns. Damit wir zum Neutronenstern beziehungsweise zum schwarzen Loch kommen können, da gehen einige Millionen Jahren. Das heisst, wenn man in traditionelle Astronomie denkt, man muss wirklich zurück in der Vergangenheit beobachten. Von Zeitpunkt T gleich Null jetzt auf der Herde heißt das, man muss wirklich Deep Space Observation einfach betreiben. Das kann auch sein, dass die jetzt dermaßen so weit weg von uns sind, dass die einzige Möglichkeit, also die, die ein bisschen näher sind, haben wir eben gemessen, 40, 50, ich weiß nicht wie viele. Bei schwarzen Löchern ist genauso das gleiche, sind die nicht so viele. Und jetzt in der Hoffnung, dass mit der Gravitationswellenastronomie wir ein bisschen mehr Himmel einfach sehen können, ein bisschen mehr Universum. Und zwar nicht nur so die zwei Winkel oder XY, sondern auch zurück in die Vergangenheit, dass wir viel mehr beobachten können. Also das ist sozusagen die einzige Erklärung, die ich im Moment habe. Wenn das das letzte Stadium eines Sterns ist, dann muss ich wirklich weit weg in der Vergangenheit schauen und nicht so nah an mir dran. Und das schaffen wir nicht so weiter weg in der Vergangenheit zu gucken.
Ist das begrenzt? Also könnten jetzt neue Teleskoper helfen?
Also sicherlich helfen diese ganzen neuen Satelliten, weil die breiter werden. Also in dem die breiter werden, die decken viel mehr Tiefe. Hier auf der Erde gibt es neue Projekte, ob die wirklich auch beim Neutronenstern uns helfen können. Was man dabei macht, man macht eben die Anlage größer. Je größer das ist, desto größer ist die Abdeckung. Und man muss auch langsam gegen ganz normale thermisches Rauschen kämpfen, weil je kleiner meine Signale werden, das ist der Grund, warum bei LIGO und Virgo 30 Jahre einfach gedauert hat. Weil wenn ich dann diese winzig kleine Signale messen will, dann muss wirklich das normale thermische Rauschen, das Elektronen und Atomen in dem Retikulen von einem Material sich einfach bewegen. Die bleiben nicht still. Die müssen einfach zu null reduziert werden, weil ansonsten messe ich einfach Rauschen. Und das ist, wo eben die neuen Technologien helfen. Ob wir dadurch viel mehr aussehen können. Ich verspreche mir viel mehr von den Gravitationswellen, weil die geben uns jetzt einen Blick wirklich viel mehr weiter in die Vergangenheit, als wir bisher beobachten könnten. Und vielleicht sehen wir mehr davon.
Die ja wirklich das erste Messinstrument sind, die wirklich mit dem Sacreis, der in China umfällt und mit dem Schmetterlingsflügel, der irgendwo in Japan geschlagen wird, ein echtes Problem haben. Das irgendwie alles nochmal rausrechnen muss. Wie viel kann man sich denn aus dieser Neutronen-Sternforschung noch an grundlegenden Erkenntnissen versprechen? Ich meine, diese Kompressibilität scheint mir ja schon etwas extrem Grundsätzliches zu sein. Wenn man die also näher bestimmen könnte über diesen Weg, lässt das ja dann im Umkehrschluss wahrscheinlich einfach eine ganze Menge wiederum an Rückschlüssen zu, für die Teilchenforschung an sich. Und um es mal richtig auf die Spitze zu treiben, man könnte ja dann vielleicht auch so der eigentlichen Problematik der Weltformel, dessen was sozusagen die großen und die kleinen Theorien zusammenbringen soll, näher kommen. Oder ist das übertriebene Hoffnung?
Nein, in dem Sinn, ich nehme mal einen Beispiel. Also wir gehen, das habe ich vorher auch gesagt, wir gehen davon aus, dass bei einer Neutronensterne an der Oberfläche Elektromagnetismus so gilt, wie wir den kennen. Eigentlich die Tatsache dieser, man kann das so auch nennen, Grand Unified Theories, diese Weltformel. Die gehen alle davon aus, wir kennen die vier fundamentale Kräfte. Wir rechnen mal zurück in die Vergangenheit. Irgendwann musste nur eine Kraft einfach da sein. Und einige sind schwächer geworden, die starke Wechselwirkung, einige sind stärker geworden. Und das geht aber davon aus, dass Elektromagnetismus, Gravitation, alle, die wir kennen, so einfach sind, unabhängig davon, mit welchen Massen wir zu tun haben, mit welchen Skalen wir zu tun haben. Und Neutronsterne, da könnte man sagen, man könnte das auch bei schwarzen Löchern testen. Glücklicherweise sind schwarze Löcher nicht freundlich. Neutronsterne sind sozusagen das, würde ich mal sagen, das Extremlabor, das das Universum uns bietet, das wirklich zu testen. Also sind die Naturkonstanze, die Kräfte, wie wir die kennen, unabhängig davon, mit welchen verrückten Dinge wir zu tun haben, bezüglich Massen, Rotationen und und und. Wenn man das auch noch dazu testen könnte. Also brechen die Maxwell-Gleichungen an der Oberfläche eine Neutronenstern? Ja oder nein? Das wissen wir nicht. Im Moment nehmen alle Rechnungen die Maxwell-Gleichungen, wie sie sind, weil wir keine andere kennen. Wir haben die weit und breit getestet. Glücklicherweise nie an einem System, der 3 Solarmassen hat und der wie verrückt spinnt. In dem Sinne von nicht spinnen Kopf, sondern sich dreht. Das ist der Punkt, auf Englisch heißt das Pin. Wenn wir das testen könnten, dann wären wir schon ein Stück weiter in dieser Aussage. Wir wissen, wie diese Weltformel ist. Wobei es keine Weltformel ist. Man redet über eine Theorie der Grand Unification, der große Vereinheit. Das ist ein unmögliches Wort auf Deutsch. Aber als Grand Unified Theorie wären wir ein Stück näher dran. Da würden wir sagen, wenn Elektromagnetismus auch so bleibt wie bei unserem tagtäglichen Leben, selbst wenn wir bei drei Sonnenmassen sind, da kann man ein bisschen mehr glauben. Das heißt, im Prinzip, meiner Ansicht nach, wird uns in der Richtung helfen, wenn wir aber viel mehr Signale bekommen können. Das braucht sicherlich viel mehr Modellierung. Im Moment versuchen wir, wenn man einen Vergleich machen würde, wir sind gerade wie bei Kepler, der einfach versucht hatte, alle Umlaufzeiten und Perioden der Planeten einfach schön einzuformulieren mit ein paar Formeln. Wir sehen, dass wir in der Zeit, wir wissen, es soll so sein, von Kepler bis zum Einstein. Das hat ein bisschen gedauert, man hat aber angefangen, die Sache systematischer einfach zu verstehen. Und wir sind beim Neutronenstern wirklich noch beim Kepler. Wir beobachten, wie wir tabulieren die fleißig, wie schnell die rotieren, wie schwer die sind und was wir annehmen als Radius. Und wir probieren im Labor unter der Erde herauszufinden, was lässt die Kernmaterie auf sich zu, ohne zu meckern. Und in dem bin ich sicher, die Gravitationswellen werden einen wesentlichen Beitrag leisten.
Das macht es auch gut nachvollziehbar, warum die jetzt den Nobelpreis für Physik in diesem Jahr gerade erhalten haben. Da ruhen alle Hoffnungen drauf.
Endlich mal hat Einstein seinen Nobelpreis bekommen für die Allgemeine Relativitätstheorie, das er nicht bekommen hatte.
Ja, Conchettina, jetzt sind wir irgendwie am Ende angekommen. Gibt es noch irgendeine wichtige Botschaft, die wir noch mit auf die Reise schicken sollten? Am Ende, die wir noch nicht ausgesprochen haben?
Ja, ich würde mal sagen, es würde jeder Mensch helfen, in seinem Umgang mit dem anderen Mitmenschen, einfach an dem erstmal Leben und Tod eines Sterns immer wieder denken. Und dann einfach sehen, erst mal, wenn man sich an einen Neutronenstern vergleitet, sind wir nichts. Wenn man immer über das Universum denkt, man fühlt sich nicht so etwas Besonderes. Und wenn man an dem Leben eines Sterns und was das dieser Stern überhaupt tut, um uns dann unsere Atomen zu geben, der lässt sich explodieren. Das ist nicht so freundlich. Vielleicht mal den Blick zu den Mitmenschen anders werden, weil die sind genauso sternenstaub wie ich. Also das finde ich eigentlich das Großte an dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Ohne Sternexplosion keine Goldkettchen. Ich sage vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zu den Neutronensternen und anderen philosophischen Betrachtungen und vielen Dank an alle, die hier zugehört haben. Geht wieder weiter mit Raumzeit.